my stepson handed me some computer game
today on his app and said you know
builder you can build a rocket just by
dragging and dropping and everybody at
the table did it and there and then you
you know launch it
everybody's rocket went at least like
nine meters or more mine blew up on the
launch pad hi and welcome to a special
episode of two teachers I'm here today
with Audra McDonald tawny Emmy and
Grammy award-winning actors and singer
so as a working woman your wife and
you're a mom of four how do you manage
to balance working life um I still
haven't figured that out Talia and
that's the truth I mean all I know is
that I'm very driven I'm very motivated
to continue to work on my career and I'm
very motivated to be the best mother
that I possibly can be so every day it's
just about putting one foot in front of
the other figuring out how I'm gonna
work out the day knowing what my
priorities are and that is to do good
work and be there for my kids what are
your impressions of MIT I I guess I had
sort of like a myopic idea that these
you know they'll just be all heads and
books and you know whatever and just you
know brainiacs who aren't looking up you
know running into walls because they're
too busy studying everything but you
guys are so vivacious and so full of
life and so so curious about everything
and you seem to be doing it from such a
place of wonder and joy and so my hope
for you guys and you will always hold on
to that we are at MIT so I will ask you
a little bit about homework oh so what
kind of homework do you do when you're
preparing for a role or a performance
yeah I mean it's the same way as if you
were to research you know for any of the
projects that you guys have to research
I you know like when I was doing Billie
Holiday I listened to almost every album
that she ever made I interviewed anyone
that I could that was alive that knew
her you know when you're playing a
character you have to you know
everything that you possibly can about
that character so that you could inhabit
them in the most sort of organic way
what was your first major role and how
did you get it what do you consider
major he's like something that I got
paid for or just my first big role what
was major to you I think the first role
that I got that was major to me was I
played Reno Sweeney as a freshman and
anything goes at my at my performing
arts high school that I went to and it
was very scandalous because some
freshman got the lead role when it
should have been a senior and they they
let a freshman get the role do you have
a favorite role I don't you know people
ask me that and I really don't because I
feel like the roles you get so intimate
with a role they're like your children
you know they're all your very intimate
with them in there and they're special
to you for different reasons at
different times so I can't really pick
one that's a favorite yeah I love them
all for different reasons what is your
advice for people who want to pursue a
career that seems kind of risky like
music or acting yeah you know what's my
advice my advice is follow your heart
you know there is the old adage that if
you love what you do you'll never work a
day in your life and I think that's only
partly true because there are some days
that it does feel like work just be
willing to put in the work so don't go
into it because you want to be famous if
you're going into music or the arts as a
career go into it because you love it
because it's there there are days that
it'll be a feast and then there are just
as many and sometimes even more days
where it's famine so you better make
sure you love what you do this is more
of a personal question
but when you're at Juilliard I know that
you suffered from depression hmm would
you mind telling me kind of how you got
past that and what advice you would have
for students at MIT and other schools
who are just kind of overwhelmed exactly
yeah
I know I'm very open about what happened
to Juilliard I tried to ride to kill
myself when I was there and I was the I
you know asked for help on my student
director advisor took me and they put me
in a mental hospital which is where I
stayed for a month and got the help that
I needed I let myself get really
overwhelmed and I I don't blame myself
for that but I didn't ask for help so
what I would say to any student
is first of all it's not your fault and
what especially in high-pressure schools
like MIT and Julliard and it's servitor
situations already you know whatever it
is reach out and ask for help if it
means that you know you go to whatever
sort of mental health services they have
for you within the school or talk to a
friend or if you you know if you're
religious and you belong to sort of some
sort of house of worship ask for help
there is nothing wrong with needing help
but ask for it yeah so I guess now we're
gonna transition to some more some
lighter questions so these are kind of
rapid-fire questions okay oh god this
feels like a test it's not okay do you
have any daily rituals okay that works
what are some traditions or
superstitions you practice ooh the the
typical theatre ones you do not whistle
in a theatre you do not say the Scottish
play in a theater unless you were doing
the Scottish okay another one is I don't
I don't like to visit with people who
are attending a performance I'm doing I
do not like to visit with them before
the show but I stay on my own and very
quiet so that when I get out there I've
centered myself and I can be open and
present in the moment and I feel like
you can't do that if you're giving away
all your energy beforehand given the
choice of anyone in the world Dead or
Alive who would you want to have as a
dinner guest
only one person okay I would choose it
would be like a super boozy dinner but I
would choose Billie Holiday and Judy
Garland oh my gosh I would be the one
just trying to pick everybody up at the
end of the night but that would be an
amazing dinner party how do you relax
when I'm dry it like I'm driving home
from the studio from the set or
something like that I'm an open book so
I just I admit stuff but I listen to
forensics files the radio it's a TV show
that will play on the radio if you have
serious sex with many just plugging
things it's all these you know murders
that are that were solved by forensics
it's so it's a bit macabre but for some
reason I find it fascinating I find
those stories of how they solve all
these things
fascinating so this is kind of a fun one
but if you were an MIT student you know
what major would you want to be I can't
even answer that question because they
would never in a million years happen
nothing okay well could I study forensic
science and I mean so that I could like
you know salsa also have archaeology Oh
archaeology okay I know because I could
travel to places and do digs and stuff
okay archaeology if you had a warning
label what would it say talks too much
okay I know that you're super passionate
about LGBTQ rights do you want to tell
me a little bit more about your work in
that field I you know I've grown up in
the theater and a lot of my close
friends a lot of people in my family are
LGBTQ and you know I I was pretty vocal
in the fight for marriage equality not
only within the cut within the country
but within our state actually as well
and I also work closely with LGBTQ
homeless youth as well and my work at
the covet I'm on the board of directors
of the Covenant house which is a
homeless shelter for youth all across
the country and in Canada so we try and
be a soft landing place for them my last
question is the question that I asked to
all the guests on tea with teachers
limits if you could give any piece of
wisdom to MIT students they're just
students in general what would it be
this is what's flying into my head right
now so I'm gonna trust my gut what's
unique about how you will impact
whatever field you go into is you what
you bring that's unique about yourself
and so the Sondheim quote I then would
say would be anything you do let it come
from you then it will be new give us
more to see
thank you for watching this week's
episode of tea with teachers if you
liked what you saw subscribe and watch
more videos here follow us on social
media here if you have suggestions for
questions or professors let us know down
in the comments below have a great week